now as they try to find their footing in
this red-hot Trump economy the 2020
Democrats are resorting to hyperbole an
endless and predictable personal attacks
their instinct is to demean not debate
our nation that believes ripping
children from the arms of their parents
at the border but Trump does so you
definitely would agree that he's a
racist I do yes yes we have a president
today who is a racist who is a sexist
who is a religious bigot but that is the
damn truth no Bernie it's not the darn
truth I'm not saying your word now this
is all sound and fury signifying zip and
it's hard to see that any of this is
really moving the needle with
independence or heaven forbid Trump
voters did in the absence of a
compelling agenda the Democrats are left
to marinate in their own radicalism and
how extreme have they become well they
now believe that the Constitution allows
for fully viable innocent babies both
pre born and born to be killed by the
most gruesome measures the infant would
be delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother to this day
none of the 20/20 Democrats now there
are 23 of them none of them have
condemned that statement by the still
sitting Virginia governor Northam now in
fact they all seem to be on board with
what he said but of course they call it
something else they call it women's
reproductive health or just and I love
this a choice as if we're talking about
picking out a handbag or a pair of
earrings the only ones who don't get a
choice in this equation are the baby and
the father ever there is a well-funded
attack
coordinated by right-wing extremists to
deny women the right to control their
own bodies and their own futures
I trust women to draw the line when it's
there our government should not be the
business of telling a woman what she
should do with her own body I think that
the Hyde Amendment should be repealed
and that we actually need to make sure
that women regardless of their income
level have a basic right to reproductive
care
lots of euphemisms now rather than
trying to appeal to the vast middle
class of America the Democrats are
trying to out metal one another and the
Radical Olympics and not just on the
issue of abortion but on a lot of other
cultural issues as well
for instance such as gender
identification we talked about that last
week now this radical social agenda was
originally developed and conceived in
the Academy and it was meant to upend
the old order the traditional family
structure that has been at the core of
every major civilization throughout
history in this new world order this new
world view was then mainstream by the
popular culture and eventually embraced
by Democrats and even some Republicans
and it has now become a new politically
correct orthodoxy in its extremists and
totally unyielding on issues such as
gender and abortion its adherents or
vicious if you dare disagree with their
worldview they believe that you should
lose your job and frankly be banished
forever from the public square and no
I'm not exaggerating but it wasn't
always this way
this was Barack Obama back in 2008
define marriage I believe that marriage
is the union between a man and a woman
now for me as a Christian
for me as a Christian is also a sacred
union now in his book David Axelrod
revealed that Barack Obama was lying
when he said that he was just basically
saying that to get elected a lot of
people have evolved that's for sure
well just like now we know that Hillary
Clinton was lying when she said this we
can support a woman's right to choose
that makes abortion safe legal and rare
and reduces the number of abortions what
happened to the rare part a million a
year at least now the Democrats have
unmasked themselves it's kind of
liberating the euphemism is about a
woman's choice they don't really work
anymore now that the New York State
Legislature gave itself a standing
ovation as they went far beyond the old
language and legalized infanticide yet
much of the country is becoming more
pro-life you'd never know it by reading
a lot of the newspapers particularly in
the later stages of pregnancy this has
been the case for some time now
Democrats think that the new Alabama law
that outlaws most abortions they think
it gives them a huge opening in 2020
they've been looking for an opening but
as usual they miss read the country
first Alabama didn't pass the law to
score political points
Alabama's pass a law because they
believed that they were saving the lives
of innocent babies for Christians and
others who believe abortion is the
taking of an innocent life no amount of
vilification of their position by
Hollywood the news media or Alexandria
Casa Cortez anybody is going to change
their moral determination Trump by the
way recognized this in 2016 if you go
with what Hillary is saying in the ninth
month you can take the baby and rip the
baby out of the womb of the mother just
prior to the birth of the baby now you
can say that that's okay and Hillary can
say that that's okay but it's not okay
with me in normal press settings dem
Kratts are rarely asked uncomfortable
specifics about what it is abortion and
they're usually able to skate through
with generalities and bromides that
we've heard a thousand times before now
Trump I don't think let's his opponents
glide by so easily and second regarding
those so-called experts who think that
the social issues are gonna hurt
Republican prospects I'll remind you
that many of these same experts have
been saying the same thing since Roe vs.
Wade was decided back in 1973 and
remember these are many of the same
people who said Trump would lose in 2016
for the same reasons Trump's comments on
abortion and his vow to select Supreme
Court justices who would overturn Roe
versus Wade likely won't help his
to women voters
Donald Trump has no idea about women
about women's health and his entire
campaign has been this scorched-earth
attitude just one question who's in the
White House today and that's the angle